what we're going to do in this video is
explore continuity over an interval but
to do that let's refresh our memory
about continuity at a point
so we say that f
is continuous
when
x is equal to c
if and only if so i'm going to make
these two way arrows right over here the
limit
of f of x
as x approaches c
is equal to f of c
and when we first introduced this we
said hey this looks a little bit
technical but it's actually pretty
intuitive think about what's happening
the limit as x approaches c of f of x so
let's say that f of x as x approaches c
is approaching some value so if we
approach
if we approach from the left we're
getting to this value if we're
approaching the right we're getting this
value well in order for the function to
be continuous if i had to draw this
function without picking up my pen well
the value of the function at that point
should be the same as the limit that's
this is really just a more rigorous way
of describing this this notion of not
having to pick up your pencil this
notion of connectedness that you don't
have any jumps or any discontinuities of
any kind
so that out of the way let's discuss
continuity over intervals
let me delete this really fast so i have
space to work with
so we say
so i'm going to first talk about an open
interval and then we're going to talk
about a closed interval because a closed
interval gets a little bit more involved
so we say f
is continuous
over
an open interval from a
to b so the parentheses instead of
brackets this shows that we're not
including the endpoints so this would be
all of the points between x equals a and
x equals b but not equaling x equals a
and x equals b so f is continuous over
this open interval
if and only if
if
and only if
f is continuous
over
every point in every over every
point
in
the
interval
so let's do a couple of examples of that
so let's say we're talking about the
open interval from negative seven to
negative five
is f continuous over that interval
let's see we're going from negative 7
to
negative 5.
and there's a couple of ways you could
do it there's the not so mathematically
rigorous way where you could say hey
look if i start here i can get all the
way to negative 5 without having to pick
up my pencil
if you want to do more rigorously and
you actually had the definition of the
function you might be able to do a proof
that for any of these points over the
interval that the limit as x approaches
any one of these points of f of x is
equal to the value of the function at
that point it's harder to do when you
only have a graph when you only have a
graph you can only just do it by
inspection and say okay i can go from
that point to that point without picking
up my pencil so i feel pretty good about
it
now let's do another interval
let's say the so let me put a check mark
here that is continuous
let's think about the interval from
negative 2
to positive 1 the open interval
so this is interesting because the
function
at negative 2 is up here and so if you
really wanted to start negative 2 you
would have to start here and then jump
immediately down as soon as you get
slightly larger than negative 2 and then
keep going
but this is an open interval so we're
not actually concerned with what exactly
happens at negative two we're concerned
what happens when we are
all the numbers larger than negative two
so we would actually start right over
here
and then we would go
to 1 and once again based on the
intuitive i didn't have to pick up my
pen idea this function would be
continuous over
this
over this interval
so what's an example of a of an interval
where the function would not be
continuous well think about the interval
from
well this is a pretty straightforward
one the open interval from 3 to 5.
the function is here when x is equal to
3 but if we wanted to get to 5 it looks
like we're asymptoting
it looks like we're asymptoting up
towards infinity and we just keep on
going for a very long time and then we
would have to pick up our pencil and
jump over
and then we would come back
down right over here and so here we are
not continuous over that interval
so now let's think about the more the
slightly more involved interval the
slightly more involved case is when you
have a closed interval
f is continuous
over
the closed interval from a to b so this
includes not just the points between a
and b but a but the endpoints as well
if and only if
f is continuous
over
the open interval
and
the one-sided limits let me write this
the
limit
as x
approaches a
from the right
of f of x
is equal to f of a
and
the limit
as x approaches b
from the
left
from the left of f of x
is equal to f of
b
now what's going on here well it's just
saying that the one-sided limit when
you're operating within the interval has
to approach the same value as the
function
so for example if we said the closed
interval from negative 7 to negative 5
well this one is still reasonable you
know just based on the picking up mere
pencil thing you don't have to pick up
your pencil
and what you would do is at the end
point and at negative seven this
function is just plain old continuous
but if it wasn't defined over here it
could still be continuous because you
would do the right-handed limit towards
it and you'd say okay the right-handed
limit is equal to the value of the
function and then at this end point at
the second endpoint you'd say okay the
left-handed limit
is equal to the function even if it
wasn't defined here even if the
two-sided limit were not defined and so
we could actually look at an example of
that if we were looking at
the interval from
the close and you could have one side
open one side closed but let's just do
the closed interval from negative three
to negative 2.
so
notice i did not have to pick up my
pencil i'm including negative 3 and i'm
getting all the way to negative 2.
if you knew the analytic definition of
this function you could prove that hey
the limit at any of these points inside
between negative 3 and negative 2 is
equal to the value of the function
negative 3 the function is clearly at
negative 3 the function is just plain
old continuous the two-sided limit
approaches the value of the function but
at negative two the two-sided limit does
not exist when you approach from the
left it looks like you're approaching
zero f of x is equal to zero when you
approach from the right it looks like f
of x is approaching negative 3. so even
though the two-sided limit does not
exist we can still be good because
the left-handed limit does exist
and the left-handed limit is approaching
the value of the function so we actually
are continuous over that interval
but then if we did the interval if we
did the closed interval from negative 2
to
negative 2 to 1
pause the video and think about based on
what we just talked about are we
continuous over this interval
well we're going from negative 2
to 1
and negative 2 is the lower bound so is
this right over here is this right over
here true
is the limit as we approach negative two
from the right
is that the same thing as f of negative
two
well the limit as we approach from the
right seems to be approaching negative
three
and f of negative two is zero so this
limit does not this these two things the
limit as we approach from the right and
the value of the function are not the
same and so we we do not have that i
guess you could say that one-sided
continuity at negative two and that also
makes sense if i start at negative two
let me do this in a color you can see if
i start at negative two and i wanna go
the rest of the interval to one i have
to pick up my pencil pick up my pencil
go here and then keep on going so this
is we are not continuous over that
interval